welcome back comrade the case of
scp-2273
also known as major alexi belatrov has
sparked your imagination and you need to
know more but even if you're not
familiar with the major his story all
you need to know is that it's one of war
tragedy and alternate dimensions he
first appeared in the town of danner
wisconsin on the 13th of october 1989
during an unprecedented seismic event
when he was first discovered the
foundation researchers assumed that he
was an extraterrestrial being on account
of his advanced organic exoskeleton in a
surprising move for such an imposing
creature bellatrov gave himself up to
foundation agents without a fight major
belatrov was then impounded in
foundation containment site 17 where he
was interrogated thoroughly over a
series of interviews the foundation
ascertained that belatrov came from an
alternate timeline where russia and the
us are locked in a so-called war to end
the world thanks to advanced military
technology given to them by
scp-1000 bellatrov had nearly escaped
execution at the hands of american
soldiers and appeared in our timeline
now he is a prisoner of the advanced
suit that formally kept him alive but
his story isn't over the last remnant of
a cold war turned hot has plenty left to
teach us something that you need to
understand about the scp foundation
before we go any further is that it
doesn't only exist in every nation
across the globe it also exists in every
splinter reality across the multiverse
and these splinter realities offer a
countless multitude of tales of
different places different people and
different times today's tale concerns
major bellatrov's future in a universe
where the secrecy of the foundation is
broken and the anomalous world needs to
find a way to fit in with our own the
year was 2018 like many humanoid
anomalies that the foundation was
holding in this timeline belatrov was
released from containment he was no
longer an scp he was now a mere person
of interest free to move around as he
pleased but this didn't mean belatrov
was about to enjoy a quiet life on easy
street he was still an interdimensional
refugee from a broken alternate world
thankfully there was a certain group
willing to help the mana charitable
foundation this anomalous charity has
been involved in a number of strange
cases investigated by the foundation
before and now they were going to lend a
hand to major bellatroph thanks to their
anomaly reintegration project
mana was able to transport belatrov back
to his home of vulgrad in russia there
he became something of a national
celebrity making headlines across the
country sitting down for interviews on
every russian talk show and even being
offered book deals but as a former
military man bellatrov was eager to
return to government life and run for a
government position however this
ambition didn't go very far belatrov was
rejected by all the government bodies he
applied to even vladimir putin wasn't
eccentric enough to want an insecticide
cyborg from another dimension in this
cabinet bellatrov endured a rough two
years in volgrav he was treated more
like a sideshow freak than a human being
people didn't want to rent apartments to
him and he was never able to find
permanent employment even entry-level
jobs rejected him nobody wanted to get
food served to them by what looked to be
a seven foot monster and he seemed
equally ill-suited to help russian women
find the right perfume in department
stores in april of 2020 bellatrov had
finally had enough he contacted the mana
charitable foundation once again and
asked to be relocated they told him that
some religious institutions in the area
including the eastern clockwork orthodox
church were accepting and housing
anomalous refugees not long after this
belatrov truly fell off of the scp
foundation's radar but one former
foundation operative was well aware of
major belitrov's fate it's 2021. dr
friedrich the site-17 anomaly
psychologist who'd conducted all the
initial interviews with belatrov all the
way back in 1989
started receiving letters from him there
was no indication as to his true
location and they appeared to have been
handled by a mana charitable foundation
mail carrier in russia but dr friedrich
was happy to hear from an old friend
nonetheless due to a career of working
near highly radioactive anomalies like
bellatrov dr friedrich was suffering
from terminal lymphoma it seemed almost
like an act of divine providence that
belatrov's letters would come to him so
close to the end the two began a
correspondence and it was only after dr
friedrich's eventual death that the
letters came to the scp foundation's
attention it was from this final
correspondence that the foundation was
able to answer the big question whatever
happened to major alexi bellatrov in his
first letter to dr friedrich bellatrov
thanked him profusely he knew that dr
friedrich had been a crucial part of him
gaining freedom from the foundation and
credited the therapeutic techniques
taught to him by dr friedrich with
keeping him alive and sane to this day
bellatrov expressed a mix of amazement
at this brave new world and a sense of
profound weariness as a man eternally
locked into a weapon of war he felt
unsuited to a world in peace time he
almost missed the scorched irradiated
russia of his home dimension but most of
all he missed site 17. he missed dr
friedrich he missed some of his fellow
anomalies like
scp-507 the teleporting man and
scp-163 the spacecraft he even missed
the simplicity of being contained he
hoped that dr friedrich would write back
in his second letter bellatrov began
detailing his experience with the
eastern clockwork orthodox church
despite growing up in a highly atheistic
communist environment belatrov became
enamored with the ways of the church he
found them to be highly accepting of him
in spite of his unfortunate
circumstances they displayed a freedom
in their faith that beletrov had never
encountered before and he was eager to
be a part of it with the help of dr
friedrich belatrov was also sending
letters to some of his fellow freed
anomalies he signed off by saying that
he had even started praying something
he'd never considered before the next
letter sent in 2027 struck a much more
somber tone it was sent shortly after
bellatrov discovered dr friedrich's
diagnosis he wanted to return and see
the doctor one more time but the mana
charitable foundation wouldn't allow him
to return to site-17 believing he had
been abused during his time there
belladrove gave frederick his prayers
and well wishes and asked for a number
through which he could contact his
ailing old friend by the time the next
letter arrived in 2034 belatrov had
become a fully fledged member of the
eastern clockwork orthodox church he
referred to the other monks at the
monastery as his brothers and sisters he
seemed to have finally found a true home
there and the others fondly referred to
him by the nickname father anvil but the
true heart of the letter is bellatrov's
deep concern for dr friedrich's health
notably in this letter he often refers
to dr friedrich by his first name thomas
as though to emphasize the urgency of
the message after the deaths of several
of the anomalies that beletrov
considered friends he stated that he
couldn't handle losing anyone else his
letter ends with a poignant passage you
may be unmarried dr friedrich but you
are not unloved you have to be strong
for me you have to be strong for
yourself if you're ever worried that you
cannot find the strength to continue
think of the garden you'll plant this
spring i'd like to share gardening
photos with you again not many of my
brothers and sisters here appreciate the
simple beauty of a flowerbed or the
effort that goes into growing a patch of
vegetables it's a beauty i'd like to
continue to share trust in the power of
our lord thomas and trust in the power
of modern medicine god is smiling on you
please be strong with love and prayers
alexey
this letter arrived on the 15th of
february 2034. sadly dr friedrich had
already passed away four days earlier he
never got to see alexey's final letter
and it truly was his final letter with
nobody left for him in the world major
bellatrov stops sending any
correspondence what we know about the
final years of belatrov's life all comes
from a few scattered journal entries
translated from russian after his
passing they provide clues as to the
kind of life he lived during the 29
years the foundation could not account
for his whereabouts and his actions the
first entry written on january 7th 2035
paints a grim picture of bellatrop
feeling broken and isolated in the
monastery he wrote today is the day that
our monastery celebrates the birth of
our lord however i feel no desire to
celebrate all of my friends in this
world are dead my brothers and sisters
are partaking in some celebration
outside my dormitory all of their
required ceremonies are complete neither
they nor whatever is happening out there
will lighten my
bellatrov also wrote about losing the
comfort he once had in his faith and his
doubts about whether he would be able to
recapture that comfort but he had
survived greater traumas than this and
he would continue to press on as the
months turned to years and the years
turned to decades belatrov climbed
through the ranks of the monastery
seeing as the eastern clockwork orthodox
church practically worshipped the
concepts of industrialization and
mechanization the fact that belatrov was
permanently encased in a biomechanical
exoskeleton probably made him seem even
more pious to his holy brethren the
final piece of evidence collected by the
foundation into the life and times of
alexi belatrov came just over 20 years
later in a final address written to
comfort his followers in preparation for
his own death belatrov recounted the
details of his own life being born into
a world of fire death and mushroom
clouds then his life being suddenly
saved by forces beyond his control only
to place him into containment for almost
30 years
it was only after accepting the
teachings of the church and accepting
the clockwork goddess that he felt he
was truly free from his past in this
final note belotrov lay out some of the
teachings of his new religion the belief
in a great mechanized goddess who
planned all of reality according to
belatrov everything in her design fits
together perfectly like cogs in a
machine turning and twisting in unison
to create an ideal world he hoped to be
forgiven for the many violent sins he
committed in his military life and that
his contributions to this new world were
valuable at the very end of his address
belatrov wrote i do not believe that my
time in this world is much longer
brothers and sisters when my time of
judgment comes do not mourn me i would
rather you remember these words the
goddess is most pleased with those who
see kind non-violent resolution to their
problems because a machine whose gears
grind against each other is a machine
that cannot work see truth but also
compassion the words are only words seek
out truth within them god bless you all
father anvil a month after authoring
this statement records indicate that
alexey belatrov was found dead in his
room having passed away peacefully in
his sleep from natural causes he lived a
warrior's life but died a humble
priest's death the true tragedy in the
strange life of major alexi belatrov is
how little choice he had in his
circumstances but thanks to this tale we
know he did what he could with the life
he was given his remains lay within the
graveyard at the eastern clockwork
orthodoxy monastery where he spent the
last years of his life with a life as
difficult as his own we can only imagine
he's glad to finally rest now check out
scp-2273 major alexei bellatrov for a
more in-depth retelling of the original
story and
scp-5000 y the full story compilation
for more insanity from another dimension